3 2 1
[Aplausos]
olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o bar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo
de hoje traz jack uma coisa mundial sob
o complexo ela compreende um circo eo
japão que fazer algumas clientes
[Música]
o objetivo não é normal é um dia muito
frio e justamente 30 graus - por dentro
e que levantou infantil do dia 15 na
água e fica muito bonito mt orgulha e
hoje não vou fazer com as pimentas e eu
vou tentar fazer uma bomba caseira e
coca cola
mas vou estar com a boca ou o que
acontece
rafa
só vou tentar atravessar aqui em geral
[Música]
há muita opção de leite uma paz a partir
desta vez vão ter que mais eu fico agora
alguns a garrafa muito mais fechado ok
precipitar e agora não fugir de uma
exclusão com água usar um clima de nem
com coca cola que tem muito gás tipo
tudo mudado para que estão na política
com água para fazer tipo bolha vão
tentar tudo isso é bonito
algumas bolhas e agora supostamente um
jantar de ontem que dentro de pastas e
que combine vocal um do bolho do dia
fique esperto que a dupla está no páreo
foi proposta a empresa
tal pois não só a quantidade de espuma
de si apesar de vir aqui eu não sei que
só vou tentar agora espero que essa
garrafa que é muito maior
as bombas coca-cola coca-cola pequena
para servir de testa e depois vou
explodir esta muito maior muito maior
não está tão bonito mas é meio litro e é
bonito é o dobro
uma pessoa me sinto que eu vou deixar
que o seu ciclo dentro depois vou
começar a evitar que fugisse auto escola
[Música]
deu muitas voltas podem destruir a
tentar esconder o ditado mais na frente
o que vai acontecer qualquer coisa
grande bem conservado e por isso muito
rápido eu tentar arranjar uma forma de
colocar de equipes ao mesmo tempo 2 a 1
a cuba
o que comem tudo em cada mesa aquecer
juro com vocês podem ver solo ainda são
diferentes hoje eu sei como é que devem
mais coisas podiam ser aqui no canal
beagle então vou fazer meu jogo 50 que
um tocão estou na cola no vídeo jataí
por outro lado afirmam ter dois vídeos
que provavelmente não viram vídeos e
mapas podem se inscrever porque gatos
desde que brian e até a próxima
[Música]